bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir
edouard philippe
l'incontournable le premier ministre
grand favori au havre pour les
municipales se retrouve au coeur de
l'équation d'emmanuel macron les
français le credit du succès du thé
confinement mais rien absolument rien ne
garantit son avenir à matignon alors que
va faire le président de la république
on va parler politique ce soir dans ça
vous regarde et du grand chambardement
qui se prépare on évoquera aussi les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat à l'heure où les
températures flambent à nouveau sur la
planète
la balle est désormais dans le camp des
députés à eux de décider ce qui fera
l'objet d'une loi
parmi les 149 mesures proposées pour
réduire le réchauffement climatique et
parmi elles le crime déco side
de quoi s'agit-il l'éclairage de nos
invités dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission enfin dans ma journée à
l'assemblée
thomas des prêts nous racontera la
passion des politiques pour les animaux
de compagnie vous verrez un rapport
parlementaire été remis à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui voilà pour le programme
c'est parti ait accès vers n'oubliez pas
on livre
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
il faut remonter à alain juppé pour
retrouver un premier ministre en
campagne aux municipales digne héritier
regardez ces images
edouard suivi par fable sans cravate
dans les rues du havre ce week-end son
fief normand le destin politique de ce
fils de dockers à vrai que les français
ont découvert il ya seulement deux ans
et demi se joue ces jours-ci bonsoir
jean baptiste moreau est ravie de vous
retrouver en direct cette députée à la
république en marge de la creuse où vous
dirai comment vous vivez vous
personnellement ce moment où le temps
politique simple un peu suspendue quelle
est l'ambiance au groupe parlementaire
au mouvement je rappelle que votre nom
circule peut-être pour le ministère de
l'agriculture le salut carole barjon
bonsoir mon show merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes éditorialiste à l'ops chef du
service 10 ans us sont des pages idées
et controverses de l'hebdomadaire et
frédéric dabi bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là directeur adjoint de l'ifop
pour tout comprendre de l'opinion dans
ce moment charnière alors on va
commencer donc par le cas edouard
philippe si j'ai bien compris c'est un
casse tête stéphane blakowski et qu'on
accueille tout de suite
[Musique]
davantage discuter dans le couloir vous
allez bien très bien
et vous ben moi parole alors si j'ai
bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris myriam le président de la
république a un gros problème mais c'est
plus qu'une épine dans sa chaussure
c'est carrément un boulet tu prennes à
sa cheville son problème c'est qu'il a
un excellent premier ministre avant cela
c'est la tuile
et ça c'est un problème des traits et
rabat évidemment évidemment meriam non
mais imaginez si seulement si seulement
edouard philippe je n'ai pas fait des
gaffes en permanence comme castaner pas
si dégradé des propos un peu confus
comme comme muriel pénicaud
ce n'est pas la même il était un petit
peu transparent comme franck riester à
la vie du président ce serait beaucoup
plus simple comme ça ils sont rhabillés
pour l'été on va dire pourquoi ça
pourquoi vous êtes gentil de me poser la
question vraiment une question quel tout
le monde connaît la réponse pourquoi pas
parce que s'ils avaient de gros défauts
dans filles ça serait beaucoup plus
simple de le virer
mma qu'on veut prendre un nouveau chemin
donc rien de tel pour ça que de me
nommer un nouveau premier ministre on
est comment faire pour virer quelqu'un à
qui on n'a quasiment rien à reprocher ça
se passe rien à reprocher là il n'a que
des qualités
non c'est vrai que la critique de duc
auteur d'un virus a été quand même la
gestion de la crise surtout par
gouvernement était très critiqué et donc
on pouvait s'attendre à ce que le
premier ministre a tenu comme
responsable finalement de ses erreurs de
ses ratés et gueugnon par conséquent sa
courbe de popularité plonge et en fait
c'est exactement le contraire
elle grimpe vers le ciel il a pris plus
de ceux dont les sondages 12 14 points
pendant la crise et donc en creusant
encore plus le trou avec emmanuel macron
gaming il est largement plus populaire
vers vous avez vu que l'opposition soit
régal donc jean luc mélenchon avait déjà
toujours témoigné de l'estimé en tout
cas pour les voir philippe laylle le
couvre d'éloges en disant qu'il élégant
agréable à côtoyer même temps à voyez
vous même vous vous trouvez que des
qualités alors en revanche quand
mélenchon parle de deux présidents bien
sûr il trouve que c'est un bandit on va
pas lui faire confiance donc même
tactique chez marine le pen qui quand on
lui demande mais comment se fait-il qu'à
voir philippe soit aussi populaire
ben allen réponse toute trouvée on
écoute je pense que il est apparu avec
des qualités inverse de celle du
président de la république c'est à dire
avec une forme de modestie
de clarté qui n'est pas qu'ils ne sont
pas les qualités premières d'emmanuel
macron c'est à dire qu'il va finir par
devenir un vrai rival
tant qu'il reste à matignon il ya pas de
raison qu il vienne arrive à la fin
c'est quelqu'un qui sont toujours plutôt
d'un moyen de la loyauté pour le
président de la république lukula du
papier à cigarette qui ne saurait pas
les séparer en revanche si les murs et
de matignon
ah bah oui ah bin là ça change la donne
forcément un berger parce que j'ai
remarqué comment été prise la une de
paris match de semaine dernière on l'a
vu apparaître le china moutarde le
fameux chinaud moutarde et les mocassins
italien ben en fait ça va très bien pu
être la légende de cette photo sera pu
être la nouvelle vie d'edouard philippe
après son départ de matignon
voyez il serait là dans les rues du
havre en train de se promener bien sûr
il aurait été réélu dans ce scénario
enfin décontracté enfin détendu lui même
et puis d'ailleurs quand on l'a
interrogé hier soir sur france 3 le 10
mai enfin si vous êtes élue à la mairie
du havre
est-ce que vous allez quitter matignon
bah je sais pas vous allez donner sa
réponse il va pas l'air d'être
déterminée pour s'accrocher à matignon
l'écoutent mon objectif c'est d'être
maire du havre vite ça peut arriver très
vite si ça arrive très vite
ce sera très bien le seul hic c'est
qu'il n'est pas tout à fait sûrs d'être
réduit les favoris mais est-ce qu'il va
très bas non bien sûr il est favori donc
il peut être battu ce qui serait
évidemment une super nouvelle pour
vaincre enfin une mauvaise nouvelle pour
la majorité n'en n'oublierez vite parce
coop on aurait une bonne raison pour
changer de premier ministre est d'abord
philippe donc finalement c'est si c'est
pas le cas ça sera le dilemme pour
emmanuel macron foot il ou pas virer le
premier ministre est qu'il ya deux
écoles dans ce cas là donc d'un côté
nicolas sarkozy dont il y avait gardé
fillon qu'à la fin n'a pas été réélu et
de l'autre françois hollande qui a
changé de premier ministre et qui à la
fin n'a pas été réélu c'est en fait
c'était officiel est ici de savoir
quelle est la meilleure des deux options
entre les deux le décor est planté je
fais quand même d'abord vers
l'observatrice la journaliste politique
carole barjon quand vous entendez dire
ça au fond si j'arrive au havre vite
c'est bien si c'est très vite sait très
bien comment vous comprenez cette petite
phrase là il garde ses nerfs dans cette
situation a de toute façon oui d'avoir
il vaut mieux quand on est un homme
politique et quand on est premier
ministre
et de toute façon il avait parfaitement
compris que depuis un moment quand
emmanuel macron annoncé vouloir se
réinventer il avait parfaitement traduit
que ça pouvait vouloir dire nouveau cap
changement et donc et donc changement
pour moi également
et tout lui rêve vraiment pardon tout
lui raid c'est à dire qu'il reste ou
qu'il parte que macron s'en sépare ou
pas ça lui va franchement il n'a pas
envie de rester au fond je pense que
tout premier ministre a envie de rester
mais en même temps s'il partait ce
serait pas un drame parce qu'il part
comme on vient de le dire en étant
extrêmement populaire en ayant faim en
tout cas beaucoup plus que qu'emmanuel
macron actuellement il a parce que ce
que vous avez dit que la gestion de la
crise avait été mauvaise oui au début de
l'été précisément celui qui a rattrapé
le coup si j'ose dire
c'est edouard philippe alors que manuel
macron a donné quand même le sentiment
assez souvent d'être beaucoup plus
floues et au fond presque 2 comment dire
devenir d'eau ne se réservaient des
bonnes nouvelles mais de manière très
flou avant que les plans de
déconfinement succès fille soit annoncée
bon donc
edouard philippe est apparu comme un
homme rigoureux way qui savait
d'ailleurs dire éventuellement bah voila
je ne sais pas tout transparent dans une
forme d'humilité qui a été apprécié donc
s'il devait quitter matignon il le
quitte pas sous les quolibets et les on
a l'impression qu'ils se préparent à
quitter matière il est obligé il ya eu
trop il ya eu trop de messages en
provenance de l'elysée
kiki ce qui est bien c'est à dire moi je
suis fidèle je suis loyal
si on tranche la tête vraiment ça sera
une injustice totale pour que bastien
pour ça que ça pose un problème à
maquereau évidemment sur les municipales
d'un mot pied ensuite on va regarder
vraiment attentivement ce ce bond dans
l'opinion avec vous frédéric c'est
gagner ou pas complètement sûr au vu du
premier tour on va regarder les les
scores 1 43,6 pour edouard philippe 35,8
pour son principal adversaire donc en
course 1 le communiste jean-paul lecoq
les verts 8,28 et le rassemblement
national à 7,31 s'est ouvert c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que ma part d'un candidat
communiste de très très ouvert et très
mais bon moi je alors je laisse je vais
laisser la parole à à frédéric dabi au
moins vingt minutes malterre qu'ils
adorent philippe sera élu est aussi
votre avis et frais devront réaliser une
enquête ya une dizaine de jours pour
paris normandie et sud radio un avantage
pour edouard philippe 53% et capitaliste
au sa dynamique de premier tour mais
c'est vrai c'est une vie qui était très
longtemps au parti communiste français
le coq est un très bon candidat il ya
doute sur va-t-il occupé le fauteuil de
maire de haybes tout de suite ou plus
tard c'est plutôt bien parti pour lui la
dynamique de premier tour joue malgré la
séparation de deux mois et demi entre le
premier tour et le second tour même si
la mobilisation n est pas là
l'abstention la participation qui va
être sans doute faible est une véritable
inconnue et puis est-ce qu'il va
capitaliser sur cette extraordinaire
vous disiez très bien popularité parce
que et la moitié des français approuvent
son action il alouettes moi j'avais
parié en semaine de petit état de grâce
je maintiens mes propos c'est rarissime
qu'un prêt ministre remonte on sait très
bien que la popularité souvent un chemin
sans retour et là sauf cas exceptionnel
première fois manuel valls était
retourné au déterrement te tuer 50 mais
c'était dans un contexte dramatique
d'attaqués terroristes
là il est devenu il est redevenue
majoritaire et surtout c'est lui qui
tient l'édifice mac rognant sur son
positionnement à droite quand on regarde
sa popularité tandis dans les segments
des plus acquis au vote de droite chez
des personnes âgées 62%
macron seulement 44 chez les
sympathisants de droite républicains qui
n'ont jamais vu comme un traître
il aurait pu avoir cette perception 71 %
de satisfaits
emmanuel macron 44 clairement il
capitalise sur sa gestion de la crise
il échappe presque totalement à
l'omniprésence des critiques sur les
masques qui sont associés à une macro en
termes de mensonges et sur le
déconfinement et toutes les critiques
sur la faillite de l'état la pelouse de
vannes masque c'est ma comptes et la
cour
et puis et puis ce qui me frappe c'est
qu'il a une popularité qui se construit
en décalqué là ce que disait marine le
pen était tout à fait juste avec celle
d' emmanuel macron on le crédite d'une
sorte de parler vrai rocardien en termes
de sincérité je ne je ne sais pas tout
je fais des annonces en équipe quand il
ya clairement maintenant car bien ses
débuts parmi tout à fait alors il ya
clairement un doute sur l'authenticité
de l'appareil présidence je vois un peu
songeur jean baptiste euros pas du tout
fout le gendre à intervertir les rôles
et puis tout irait bien à l'elysée
c'est une excellente nouvelle on n'a pas
attendu ces derniers temps pour savoir
qu'on avait un excellent premier
ministre et du gouvernement et qui il
était utile au pays qu'il reste premier
ministre personnel alors moi j'en vois
pas de notes au président
personnellement non moi les notes c'est
plutôt sur l'agriculture ruralité la
santé mais des questions que je maîtrise
donc là dessus c'est pas moi enfin
j'espère c'est ce qu'il a à faire
globalement edwards 6 des pires c'est
aussi la continuité d'une politique on
peut pas forcément faire un tournant
forcément on peut on peut aussi
envisager des ddd des réformes dans les
périmètres ministériels on peut il ya
des ya des tas de choses qui peuvent
changer on n'est pas obligé
nécessairement pour un nouvel élan de de
changer le premier ministre est lent il
la décrit président maquereau et le
nouveau chemin il est dit que ce serait
oeil écologique solidaire dont voilà
deux mots qui sont plutôt associé à la
gauche et edouard philippe il a jamais
dit autre chose que je suis drone a été
élu en marche pour le déplacement du
clivage droite gauche donc est-ce que
solidaire c'est plus de gauche ou plus
de droits que j'en sais rien c'est au
logis aujourd'hui on voit bien que ça
traverse les parties globalement et que
ce n'est pas justement le monopole d'un
seul parti s'interrogeait dans un
instant sur le tournant social ou pas de
ce grand discours attendus probablement
dans la semaine prochaine vous disiez
legendre aurait mieux fait de se taire
et doit quitter le groupe donc non mais
c'est vrai qu'on se pose la question
quand on vous entend peut-être questions
politiques au passage
revenir sur ce que j'ai dit je le dis en
réunion de groupe ça n'aurait pas dû
sortir de la réunion de groupe c'est
simple soit j'assume que c'est passé
c'est pas nous députés et est membre de
la majorité de faire le casting
électorale de faire le casting
gouvernemental pardon et c'est au
président de la république de décider
qui sera le premier ministe qui seront
les ministres et c'est pas à nous de lui
expliquer il le sait très bien le
président de la république qu'il doit
mettre à matignon et qu'il doit mettre
dans les différents ministères concernés
que c'est tout l'édifice heures de la
macro nez qui doit être revue voire
complètement chamboulé le parti
également le groupe
on va parler de la politique qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire après la crise mais
d'abord j'aimerais faire un détour par
nos voisins européens bon soit réservé
lee j'espère que vous êtes en pleine
forme derrière votre écran
alors je rappelle que votre chroniqueur
comme chaque mardi dans cette émission
et correspondant parisien du quotidien
suisse le temps
dites nous un peu si on fait le tour des
pays européens qui gagne qui perd la
bataille de l'opinion est ce que alors
nous on a un modèle un peu particulier
un bicéphale mais il ya les mêmes
critiques elles ont été re dossier un
chez nos voisins effectivement il ya un
côté lessiveuse à ce qu ville qui a
testé les dirigeants politiques à
l'oeuvre
c'est à dire qu ont-ils aude lui est
content il fait alors il y a en
l'occurrence ceux des pays qui n'ont pas
été tout à fait confronté à une
situation vous savez emmanuel macron a
souvent parlé de la première et deuxième
ligne ça a quand même été le cas en
europe il y a eu des pays très impactées
d'autres un peu moins
si vous regardez le flanc est de
l'europe il y a eu moins de co vide et
il ya des premiers ministres ils s'en
sont fort bien sorti on pense à
constanta minnesota keith le premier
ministre grec qui maintenant pourrait
organiser des élections législatives
anticipées
est-ce que c'est grâce à son action pas
que la grèce va mieux on ne sait pas
trop le dire alors
plus près de nous il ya deux leaders qui
vraiment s'en sortent bien c'est angela
merkel 75 % de popularité soit charte
15% ça fait rêver un port indien avantha
document c'est la référence et la mère
de la nation mutti merkel tout le monde
en a parlé il y a également le président
du conseil italien giuseppe kanté qui a
su se montrer empathie qui a incarné
l'état dans une véritable tornade
l'huile et à 64% d'opinions favorables
et c'est surtout un intérêt
parce que son rival matteo salvini est
en ce moment en difficulté les sondages
sont plutôt en berne alors il y a des
perdants en revanche boris johnson alors
johnson il avait réussi quelque part
grâce à son hospitalisation a bénéficié
de la sympathie du public vous savez
qu'il a lui même été victime du coc vide
eh bien il a perdu ce capital de
confiance avec la sphère de son
conseiller dominique kaminski a traversé
l'angleterre en plein confinement
moralité et bien il n'est plus qu'à 45 %
d'opinions favorables
un autre perdant très clairement c'est
le sait le socialiste espagnol pedro
sanchez qui est en mauvaise situation la
cecc 30% d'opinions favorables et enfin
il y en a qui étaient fort avant et
qu'ils sont forts après c'est le premier
ministre néerlandais mark rutte et
emmanuel mâcon lui a rendu ce mardi
et c'est le chancelier autrichien courte
eux ils venaient de remporter des
élections législatives
ils s'en sont bien tirés tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait de faute
majeure
merci beaucoup richard pour ce tour
d'horizon un mot encore sur la
popularité d'edouard philippe frédéric
dabi on a fait une petite courbe on
s'est rendu compte que elle commença à
monter en janvier la cote d'edouard
philippe 1 33 % en janvier et qui arrive
à 50% aujourd'hui au mois de juin
donc ya pas qu un effet crise cornaglia
bis n'ont absolument pas en janvier
c'était le fait qu'il ait tenu bon pour
la réforme des retraites notamment du
côté des segments droite lrmh et son
appareil de sainte alliance entre
sympathisants et l'air et sympathisants
en marche sur l'acceptation et le fait
de transformer le pays à travers des
réformes
et puis a toujours eu une image
personnelle d'edouard philippe
extrêmement fort une sorte pour utiliser
un oxymore de giscard sympa c'est à dire
un peu raide mais proche des gens
empathique faisant quelques lapsus de
temps en temps mais parlant vrai et
c'est quelque chose qui fait qu'il a une
popularité qui s'est de plus en plus
construit en d kalck avec celle des
macros mais là où il ya une vraie
différence avec par exemple un françois
fillon qui avait été pendant quasiment
les cinq années du quinquennat plus
populaire que nicolas sarkozy sait qu'il
a des attributs personnels et notamment
il faut le dire des attributs le
leadership des attributs présidentielle
quand on dit qu'il a fait front quand on
dit qu'il a fait le job
on te dit qu'il a protégé les français
ce ne sont pas traditionnellement dé des
représentations associées à un chef de
gouvernement
france de l'état exactement le cas
chinois du président attentionné en
pologne
enfin son attaché de presse a très bien
le mien c'est une de paris match était
vraiment le bon moment et il apparaît
seul alors que le président ma chronique
est souvent la une de paris match et
avec sa femme brigitte dont il ya un
côté people chez makro que don douar
philips est toujours protégé et je me
demande si c'est pas un atout pour lui
d'avoir toujours dit ma femme mes
enfants c'est pas un truc c'est pas
majeur mais ça peut pas être question
que jamais dit moreau 7
on a l'impression que cette espèce
d'envolées dans les sondages le rend
incontournable et que d'une certaine
façon lie les mains des manuels macron
et c'est lui qui est en dynamique c'est
lui qui au fond un peu et plus dangereux
que les manuels macron qui au fond n'a
plus la liberté de faire ce qu'il veut
est ce que c'est le cas je ne vois pas
ça en termes de rivalité entre le
premier ministre et président la
république pour le coup vraiment pas je
pense pas qu'ils aient de rivalité entre
de savoir qui est plus populaire qui
l'est moins
aujourd'hui c'est le premier ministre il
est à sa tâche qui est chef du
gouvernement et le président s'il décide
de le changer il le changera je pense
pas que ce soit de tension notamment sur
le calendrier du confinement et du
déconfinement pour les avoir tous les
deux en contact assez régulier juping
l'impression mais bon voilà c'est cesser
votre gars il va est votre vision alors
maintenant je suis très content qu'on
ait un bon premier ministre
on va parler d'argent juste et c'est
quand même la vraie question c'est est
ce que le président de la république
aujourd'hui au fond a le pouvoir il a le
pouvoir constitutionnel de changer le
premier ministre évidemment mais ce
n'est pas un peu c'est vraiment un
problème politique c'est être un os de
changer de politique en gamme et peut
être l'otage d'edouard philippe parce
que c'est ce qu'on dira si jamais c'est
là où il est coincé emmanuel macron si
ils changent facile maintien pardon et
leurs philippe à matignon on dira c'est
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas faire
autrement c'est parce qu'il n'y avait
personne de rechange à la audiard et son
film
il arrive à l'extérieur et surtout parce
qu'effectivement voilà dirait quelqu'un
de populaire c'était sur lui que ce
serait au fond retombée mais est-ce
qu'un président peut être otage non
politiquement c'est impossible
en même temps il est coincé d'un vrai
vrai dilemme alors je rejoins ce que
vous dites les français ne parle jamais
dans leurs discours spontané de la
moindre rivalité entre emma vient macron
et edouard philippe et même du côté des
sympathisants dans marche on loue le
côté pack duo est pas du tout dans une
logique de duel
alors il ya quand même un précédent
qu'on peut évoquer c'est françois
mitterrand qui congédie michel rocard
alors qu'il est extrêmement populaire
on a vu ce qui s'est passé après la
popularité mitterrandie s est effondré
avant même avant les bourses les bourdes
perçu ou le jugement qu'on sera
contrastée des français sur edith
cresson
en tout cas c'est le président quel
pouvoir de remanier et de faire un
remaniement technique ou tout changer et
puis et puis il peut garder un premier
ministre parce qu'il est bon et le
premier ministre peut changer de
politique
je viens surtout week-end mais pourquoi
ce qui n'est pas membre de la république
en marche qui dit qu'il est de droite
qui dit que la poutre dois travailler
encore pour reprendre son éducation
tracts sûrs et encore la droite peut
faire un tournant social c'est possible
oui bien sûr évidemment la droite
sociale et elle a existé pendant des
années dans ce pays je peux pas dire que
de gaulle était anti sociale non par
exemple donc
donc voilà là dessus circonstances les
circonstances changent les hommes la
crise aujourd'hui tout le monde en a
tiré les leçons et je pense que ça a
modifié en profondeur les logiciels de
tout le monde et l'élection de 2017 elle
est la traduction de ça aussi c'est
c'est premier ministre certes et vient
de la droite il ya des membres de son
gouvernement qui viennent de la gauche
jean yves le drian d'autres et on est
capable de travailler tous ensemble et
est donc on n'est pas dans le dogmatisme
que ce soit le premier ministre
président de la république ou la
majorité aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
des gens dogmatique dont nous avons tiré
les leçons de 2,2 ce qui se passe nous
savons vous voir les erreurs que nous
avons fait et nous savons vous voir où
il faut aller en ce thème râlant
mais aller parce que j'évolue on parle
de décision de rupture je changerais moi
le premier en même temps on parle aussi
de travailler davantage
c'est très difficile de savoir si on est
au début de quelque chose de très
différent ou une simple continuité
il faut savoir écouter écouter à la fois
le peuple est écouté et tirer les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui on a
on a vu pendant cette crise qu'on avait
des soucis au niveau de la souveraineté
de la souveraineté alimentaire de
souveraineté au niveau de la santé et
d'un certain nombre d'industries
aujourd'hui qu'on a délaissé pendant des
années et qui sont partis ailleurs et
qu'on s'est retrouvé dans le mur à cause
de ça donc il faut savoir tirer les
leçons et réorienter sa politique en
fonction de sa fonction des enjeux
écologiques c'est un nouveau 4
souveraineté ou non aimé mais c'est pas
les hommes qui font le cap c'est la
politique que l'on va mener et les
hommes sont capables de tirer des leçons
qu'ils soient de droite de gauche ou
sont capables de tirer d'une
indépendance stratégique souveraineté ça
on comprend mais ça sera que j'imagine
certains médicaments l'alimentation ça
fait une politique il faut il faut
étudier la sociale aussi ou pas oui ce
sur le social sur la solidarité
mais on a déjà fait des choses de ce
qu'on a fait depuis deux paires s'agit
d'aller dans la continuité mais d'aller
plus fort et plus vite
mais carole barjon cela dit le tournant
social il va poser un petit problème
quand même parce que on a bien vu qu
effectivement là pendant la crise
duco vie de l'état avait effectivement
débloquer des milliards le chômage
partiel on a pratiquement nationalisé le
lâchant chômage etc
mais on va entrer dans une période
différente
à la rentrée on voit bien que là ce qui
se profile est ce qu a annoncé
d'ailleurs nicole pénicaud ce sont les
accords de performance collective ou
apparemment sain par le chantage à
l'emploi
pam avec deux chefs d'entreprise ont
travaillé pour gagner moins voilà social
se saisir de sa queue
il y aura dans pas mal d'entreprises des
baisses de salaire ou une augmentation
du temps de travail ou de suppression de
vacances bien sûr il faut que les
syndicats soient d'accord
évidemment mais on sait aussi que les
entreprises qui voudront comment dire
engager des accords de performance
collective ne sont pas obligés dû
justifier d'être en diction dans ce
mouvement social il va être non mais le
loup blanc qu'est l'enjeu des mois à
venir ça va être d'éviter du chômage de
masse qui va se réinstaller sur l'île de
se réinstaller un pays moi j'étais hier
avec des artisans et des pme de creuse
ce qui les inquiète aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si leur entreprise elle va
survivre à l'automne parce que là
aujourd'hui on s'en rend pas bien compte
encore des effets on est sûr ce n'était
joué
il ya une angoisse et la réalité des
faits est aujourd'hui un outil par
exemple les emplois aidés par exemple
arrêter la réforme sur le chômage
pourquoi pas augmenter les allocations
voilà est-ce que c'est ce genre de
mériter d'être ouverte où débutait de la
d2 trop destruction de l'entreprise est
trop de destructions d'emplois c'est peu
c'est pas que l'argent cueilli toujours
plus d'argent de l'état le but c'est que
les entreprises elles survivent qu'elle
se transforme qu'il y ait certaines
entreprises qu'ils aillent du sur des
créneaux aujourd'hui qui sont pas
notamment dans la transformation et pas
forcément plus mais travailler tout
court parce que des gens vont perdre
leur boulot tout simplement est donc
l'enjeu c'est que les autres au conte
aide les entreprises à passer le cap et
qu'elle ne détruise pas de l'emploi et
qu'elle ne détruise s'autodétruisent
passé c'est ça l'enjeu des mois qui
vient au delà du temps de travail au
delà de tout ce qu'on veut l'enjeu c'est
qu'on a des entreprises notamment des
pme et tpe qui font l'essentiel de nos
de nos emplois sur les territoires et en
france globalement qui risque de
disparaître purement et simplement parce
que le bon de commande est pas plaint
parce que parce que les commandes
repartent pas c'est pour ça que l'enjeu
de la commande publique avec les
élections qui arrivent la main il est
très fort sur les territoires parce que
tout ce qui est commune comme c'est des
facteurs importants de création de
richesses et de création d'emplois sur
le territoire parce que la commande
publique aujourd'hui en france elle est
importante pour les pour les entreprises
dans le btp dans différents secteurs
donc c'est tout ça qui est l'enjeu c'est
la relance de l'emploi et de sauvegarde
des entreprises mathis mauroy a bien
raison de nous ramener
agréé sociale qui se profile elle va
être violente on le sent bien
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent en ce moment
si difficile des français quels types de
politique c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans le contexte de 2008 où la
crise était venu par surprise comme nous
avait pas touché la crise financière il
ya une vraie surprise quand le chômage
s'est mis à monter brusquement là les
français attendent si je puis dire
la vague autant ils ont été sévères sur
la gestion du coc vide sur le plan
sanitaire au temps des français sont
était plutôt indulgent et plutôt
bienveillant sur le chômage partiel sur
tous les mesures économiques qui ont été
prises c'est vrai aussi que il ya voilà
on est à l'aube de très très mauvaises
nouvelles et c'est toujours si on
reprend les axes politiques
c'est compliqué pour un président en fin
de mandat de faire face à une crise
économique très forte second choc
pétrolier qui fait battre giscard en 80
et la défaite de nicolas sarkozy en 2012
c'est d'abord une défaite d'absence
c'est d'abord liée à une absence de
résultats soit le front du chômage
ça va aussi réorientés en alaska
politique un grand discours peut-être
une interview dans les dents les doutes
des jours qui viennent est-ce qu'il
n'est pas condamné à décevoir
quand on dit le jour d'après sera
différent du jour d'avant quand on dit
je changerais quand on dit le monde
d'après ça va être difficile d'être à la
hauteur des attentes qui daterait oui
moi je crois que les français croient de
moins en moins ce genre de discours on
voit bien dans tous les sondages et
toutes les enquêtes la défiance qui
existe à l'égard des politiques et et de
leurs promesses et c'est vrai que le
monde d'après personne lorsqu'il fallait
parler justement d'un risque
d'effondrement de l'économie il avait
été repris par emmanuel a conclu non moi
je ne parle vraiment ils avaient
manifesté et donc la question en fait
qui nous ramène au sujet précédent
c'est de savoir maintenant qu'on a
évoqué effectivement les difficultés qui
a devant nous et qui effectivement le
l'automne va être assez rude
est ce qu'au fond il n'aura pas besoin
de quelqu'un d'assez solides et qu'ils
soient légitimes aux yeux des français
ce qu'est edouard philippe
c'est je pense que dans sa décision
emmanuel macron pèsera tout ça on risque
voilà de apparaître à un grand
changement au fond c'est le changement
c'est pas les hommes c'est la politique
une nouvelle fois et aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'homme solide et et on va avoir
besoin l'automne de personnes
compétentes à leur poste donc la limite
en rien inquiet totalement d'accord avec
vous c'est jean pierre raffarin il était
sur france info hier on va l'écouter
c'est je pense que d'abord un
déboulonner ce serait vraiment une faute
de linguistique et mais ce serait
surtout une faute politique que de
chercher à avoir une agressivité vis les
voiles à déboulonner entre guillemets
doit philippe ce serait une faute
politique
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors dans ces cas
là pour retrouver un peu au fond de
dynamisme politique dans une maison
macron qui va pas bien franchement à
part c'est vous qui le dites je parle du
naufrage le groupe
je marque forcément voilà du jugement
des français mais quand on regarde le
groupe
le mouvement un remaniement dont on vous
dit qui va être un grand chambardement
voilà on se dit y'a du boulot les
municipales dont on al impression d
allisa majorité zézette des arbres en
jambes et au loin j'ai été élu au
premier tour municipal ans conseiller
municipal face au maire sortant donc
voilà j'ai non mais non je demande pas
d'applaudissements non plus c'est une
petite ville de 400 habitants mais voilà
que voilà donc où comme quoi on est
aussi ancrée sur les territoires on
n'est pas que des gens car étant
déconnecté cc c'est pas tout à fait le
même contexte avait été en 2004
oui mais il va l'être dimanche là vous
pensez qu'il va surprendre soit au
niveau du remaniement faire venir de
nouveaux visages et peut-être peut-être
au il y aura un remaniement de toute
façon ça il faut pas faire de langue de
bois évidemment qu'il va y avoir un
remaniement après ce qu'il nous faudrait
c'est un bon mise l'agriculture voyez
pas une idée qui s'appelle didier
guillaume verra je suis pas candidat je
suis très heureux député de la creuse et
et tout va bien pour moi disait il ya
trois ans avant qu'olivier ferrand
arrive avant que jean baptiste jebbari
arrive enfin il s'est pas des mauvais
ministres et ils sont pas impopulaire
que je sache dans l'opinion donc on nous
dit on nous rabâche ça depuis trois ans
qui a pas de banc de touche tous les
ministres qui sont rentrés au
gouvernement depuis sa pas franchement
été des échecs soir ça a été des plus
tôt des réussites donc moelleux
l'histoire du banc de touche je ne crois
pas cinq minutes il ya beaucoup de
compétences dans le groupe mais aussi à
l'extérieur dans les
pourquoi pas mais moi je m'entends très
bien que manuel valls était mon voisin
d'hémicycle quasiment donc voilà j'ai
appris à le découvrir et à trois ans
c'est quelqu'un de très compétent qui a
une grande expérience politique pourquoi
pas j'en sais rien c'est pas moi qui
fais le casting d'une nouvelle fois et
je pense que le président de la
république sait c'est à peu près ce
qu'il a à faire
maintenant l'important c'est le cap
c'est quelle direction donne c'est
comment on va soutenir les entreprises
comment on va soutenir la croissance
comment on va soutenir la demande
globalement pour que les entreprises
puissent limiter le choc on va dire au
niveau des pertes d'emplois c'est ça
l'important les hommes ça importe peu
peut-être des six demandes et des
contours d'aider des ministères moi je
m'occupe beaucoup d'agriculteurs et
d'écologie on voit bien que c'est très
lié que ça a souvent été antagonistes
peut-être qu'il faut rassembler ses
ministères pour arriver à enfin créer
une parfaire les uns pour crédit
agricole
je vais proposer en ya trois ans quelque
chose me dit que voilà ces propositions
le mot de la fin dans ces moments là
c'est difficile ça joue les remaniements
et les grands discours très direct
absolument pas si j'ai rarement vu un
remaniement créer un choc psychologique
bon à 20,68 peut-être mais des
françaises comme vous le disiez son mois
sur une logique de casting que sur une
logique de résultats et quand on dit
nicolas sarkozy a été battue parce qu'il
n'a pas remplacé par françois fillon par
par exemple jean louis borloo
personnellement je n'y crois pas une
seconde
eh bien merci merci beaucoup les voit
beaucoup plus clair en attendant le
discours du président merci à tous les
quatre on va parler à présent de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat à
l'heure où les températures s'affole à
nouveau 38 degrés hier en sibérie les
150 citoyens tirés au sort ont voté ce
dimanche 149 mesures concrètes au terme
de neuf mois de travail transports
énergie éducation consommation les
députés doivent maintenant faire leur
tri nathalie du loir
grégoire est l'un des 150 citoyens avoir
été tiré au sort de la convention
citoyenne
pendant neuf mois il a eu pour mission
d'élaborer des propositions pour réduire
de 40% les gaz à effet de serre en
france d'ici à 2030 et dimanche c'était
l'heure de rendre sa copie
le rapport final de la première
convention pour le climat est adoptée à
95 %
le rapport est adopté les citoyens ont
fait le choix notamment d'un référendum
sur la législation de l'écocide les
citoyens veulent sanctionner une
atteinte grave à l'environnement mais
ils ont fait aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
propositions et a eu les cendres et sang
dit qu'il remettra à la rénovation
globale lutter contre
l'artificialisation des terres
privilégier le train
inciter au développement d'une pêche à
faibles émissions les taxes sur les
transports aériens
mais toutes ces propositions ont-elles
intéresser les députés vont-ils s'en
saisir pour la majorité tout comme pour
l'opposition il y aura bien une suite l
initiative du gouvernement et du
parlement et un double intérêt à vous
voir un grand projet de loi après cette
convention citoyenne pour le climat
d'abord pour la cohérence de l'ensemble
des propositions
moi je pense qu'un grand texte qui
reprend l'ensemble des propositions
permettraient d'avoir une force et un
souffle à ce travail qui a été fait par
les citoyens si certains députés de
l'opposition sont satisfaits ils se
saisissent de cette convention nous
allons proposer
andré chassaigne portera la voix des
communes et cet après midi pour que ses
propositions ne soit pas lettre morte
qu'elle trouve un prolongement
nous allons jouer notre rôle en
demandant à ce que l'assemblée se
saisissent des propositions les examine
dans une commission spéciale d'autres
députés eux s'inquiètent d'être mis de
côté par l'exécutif qui le fait qu' il
ya des conventions citoyenne est utile
certainement nécessaire ce que je veux
pas c'est que le parlement soit
complètement absent de ce processus
démocratique là et je vois bien
aujourd'hui qu'on est en train de faire
convention citoyenne président la
république référendum et que le
parlement est exclu de tous ces
discussions donc la conviction citoyenne
c'est bien le parlement c'est mieux je
pense qu'il faut qu'elle soit
institutionnalisée et qu' il y est une
réflexion sur une réforme
institutionnelle qui organise la
participation citoyenne non pas en
concurrence des parlementaires mais en
complémentarité
il faut le faire parce que sinon il peut
y avoir la tentation notamment du
président de la république de
disqualifier par la convention citoyenne
le travail des parlementaires
emmanuel macron a fait savoir qu'ils
tiendraient compte des propositions de
la convention citoyenne il les reçoit le
29 juin à l'elysée pour leur apporter
une première réponse
bonsoir annie pata et merci infiniment
d'être sur le plateau de lcp vous êtes
donc l'une de ses 150 citoyens tirés au
sort vous rencontré emmanuel macron sais
je dis pas de bêtises c'est lundi
prochain effectivement c'est ça vous
allez nous dire exactement ce que vous
attendez du président de la république
bienvenue à vous aux meilleurs phelim
bonsoir grave il vous retrouvez député
écologie démocratie et solidarité
dim
eloi et proche de nicolas hulot et puis
bon soir philippe gosselin bonsoir même
s'ils gagnent la députée les
républicains de la manche et je salue
françois durpaire qui m'accompagne sur
ce plateau savane fabien historien
spécialiste des états unis chroniqueur
dans cette émission vous allez nous
parler de l'écologie dans la campagne
américaine totalement invisible ou pas
vous nous direz et vous pouvez
intervenir quand vous le souhaitez alors
on va commencer avec vous annie patat
quand on voit toutes les propositions
ensuite qu'elles vont très loin ses
propositions elles sont assez ambitieuse
voire audacieuse c'est étrange parce que
vous n'étiez pas tous écolos vous êtes
tous converti à l'écologie et à la lutte
pour le climat
alors nous étions pas tous écolos ils
nous le sommes pas tous
aujourd'hui l'objectif effectivement de
nos 150 propositions que c'était de
montrer que des citoyens pouvaient
porter aussi une volonté ambitieuse de
ce que pouvait nous proposer aujourd'hui
le corps public et politique d une
conversion une forme de prise de
conscience au fur et à mesure des
séances de travail et les objets
emblématiques
effectivement pour plusieurs citoyens
dès les premières sessions il ya eu
cette prise de conscience sur l'urgence
et c'est aujourd'hui le des le défi j'ai
envie de dire de faire comprendre
également l ensemble des français que
cette notion d'urgence climatique
et vraiment l'objet de ces propositions
on va en prendre quelques unes mais
c'est vrai que vous avez assez loin sur
la rénovation thermique pour le logement
vous avez plein de propositions sur la
publicité l'éducation de transport y en
a une que vous n'avez pas mis ces taxes
carbone celle là vous avez renoncé
c'est à dire qu'en fait ça n'a jamais
été l'objet d'un débat
pourquoi vous savez que les français
n'en veulent pas c'était pas la peine
alors ya eu débat au sein des 150 et on
en a discuté un il faut il faut le dire
sur le point de fiscalité
sap a été retenu comme source de
financement
mais vous allez le voir dans les
prochains jours on a proposé ce qu'on
appelle une boîte à outils avec à
plusieurs propositions autour des
financements possibles
voilà exactement et puis vous n'avez pas
voté une proposition sur sur le temps de
travail réduit à 28 heures sans baisse
de salaire
dommage parce que philippe martinez de
la cgt était très favorable mais je les
défends du serait défendu mois ci un oui
oui cette proposition alors assez
travailler moins pour gagner plus
maintenant on va tout à fait et non pas
tout à fait pas tout à fait puisqu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que dans notre
monde un on avait également la notion de
justice sociale
c'est vraiment un pape sow les mains ça
se retrouve dans toutes nos propositions
c'est peut-être l'ordre d'émission
rappelé le nou lors deviez faire des
propositions pour parvenir à quels
objectifs alors répondre à cette
question comment réduire d'au moins 40%
à nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'ici à 2030 en partant de 1990 n'ont
que ce ce délai de soixante ans on doit
réussir cet objectif est aujourd'hui on
est loin de la trajectoire de cet
objectif
et le tout dans un objectif de justice
sociale un objet dire rendre acceptable
toutes ces mesures effectivement le
compte y est
matthieu orphelin oui de toute évidence
il ya eu un travail remaniement
remarquable des 150 citoyens et
citoyennes bravo à vous et vos collègues
c'est un travail magnifique c'est huit
mois d'immersion
effectivement avec des sessions de
formation au début peut-être fera qu'on
fasse la même chose assemblée nationale
parce que je crois que vous avez pris
cette pleine conscience des enjeux
écologiques et solidaires est vraiment
moi je tiens tout ce qu'ils ont pu
ouvrir les travaux il ya des centaines
de pages de propositions mais aussi de
traduction en termes
et craie de projet de loi d'articles de
loi c'est qu'ils vont plus loin que les
députés en matière d'écologie il ya bien
nommé loin plus fort ça plus loin plus
fort vegas emploi j'imagine pas du tout
moi je trouve ça vraiment très bien que
effectivement voyage monde politique
qu'a du mal à se saisir non pas des
thèmes du climat tout le monde en parle
dans les discours il ya des actions
gouvernement a fait des choses etc
mais on n'est pas politiquement au bon
rythme parce qu'il nous manque cette
pleine conscience écologique que vous
avez su créer ensemble et donc moi je
trouve ça très bien cet ensemble de 149
proposition c'est assez drôle dans votre
question
1 vous parlez de la seule cape a été
retenu parce que sinon matin c'est aussi
de la fiscalité écologique c'est assez
drôle a fait un sujet dans laquelle il y
avait toute une certaine mesure entend
reprendre ya des mesures qui soient
constitutionnelles que naturellement
dans m la tendance est là mais les
modalités la globalité avec le nouveau
projet avec tout ça est dans les clous
de l'accord de paris la france oui
est-ce qu'on est exactement au moins 40
% on peut avoir le débat est ce qu'on
est un petit peu moins tard mais en tout
cas ça fait un vrai nouveau modèle de
société basé sur la sobriété sobriété
choisie sobriété heureuse et ça fait
aussi pour le président de la république
pour les parlementaires notamment ceux
de la majorité ça peut faire ou pas dans
ce qui va être annoncé lundi soir un
grand virage écologique et solidaire ça
qu'on appelle de nos voeux les citoyens
ont fait le travail
ils ont aussi voulez vous c'est aussi là
dessus plutôt que de dire on met tous en
référendum etc
non vous vous avez transmis au pouvoir
politique à nous avec nos collègues de
tous les bancs politique maintenant de
concrétiser cette belle ambition notre
groupe demande d'ailleurs une grande loi
d'application de la convention citoyenne
dès juillet on n'est pas là justement
c'est en vacances pour pouvoir
concrétiser vous allez tous à vous allez
répondre à ça tout philippe gaussent là
mais je voulais vous faire entendre
delphine batho parce qu'elle elle cite
ou 1 écoutez là c'était tout à l'heure
aux questions au gouvernement
inscrivons à l'ordre du jour au mois de
juillet un projet donnant force de loi
aux 149 propositions nous sommes prêts
et nous sommes prêts à y travailler tout
l'été et vous philippe gosselin pour les
républicains vont jouer le jeu vous êtes
prêts à tous
nés tous signé je vais pas vous
surprendre mais en tout cas moi je
voudrais saluer une belle aventure
collective et individuelle là-dessus il
n'y a pas de doute ya pas de mauvais
procès je doute en revanche de la
légitimité des travaux qui sortent le
débat vous le connaissez bien
je crains fortement que ça court
circuite la représentation nationale
donc les élus qui eux sont directement
responsable devant des électeurs qui ont
des comptes à rendre
donc on n'est pas tout à fait dans le
même système maintenant pourtant alors
vous pourriez avoir à faire des
propositions loin donc avec un démarrage
et des amendements déjà il ya déjà de
nombreuses propositions de loi sur le
sur le sujet sur et sur la base des
propositions ça pourrait être pris et
pourquoi pas du reste - ce que je
souhaite c'est que les élus soient dans
la boucle
ça me paraît bien la moindre des choses
on parle beaucoup de référendum en ce
moment et pourquoi pas très bien y venir
à bien qu'on saisisse nos concitoyens
sur un certain nombre d'enjeux valait
part d'être côtés l'ont été mais je
crois qu'il est important qu'ils aient
une vraie expression démocratique et pas
comme je le crains je vous le dis
franchement un peu une manipulation le
tirage au sort celle démocratique de la
bleue sur le dispositif pour vous ça
existe un lien la démocratie en été avec
6000 citoyens
on le rappellera et puis tous les autres
c'était des dizaines et des dizaines et
l'association des citoyens à la lazio
qui n'avaient pas la citoyenneté dont on
peut pas totalement transposé en
revanche sur le système tel qu'il a été
fait on a un certain nombre de personnes
qui se sont récusés qui se sont retirés
et on a retenu davantage de personnes
150 qui ont un intérêt immédiat
ils sont pas représentatifs de la
société ça ne les dévalorise pas ça ne
les désigne pas mais pour autant il ya
t'il âge qui serait un point de fer
entre le parlement cette assemblée et
nous conservons c'est très intense
termine juste parce que nous sommes
d'accord sur un sujet c'est
effectivement une nécessité
environnementale et écologique
reste à voir ce qu'on met dedans d'abord
le débat de légitimité démocratique
qu'est ce que vous répondez en tant que
tirer au sort qui avait participé à
cette convention à monsieur le député
alors merci pour un trait ses paroles
alors c'est une question qui est revenue
dès le début de la convention est ce que
vous êtes légitime en tant que tirer au
sort est ce que vous êtes représentant
des 65 millions de français et moi voici
ma réponse
la légitimité ont l'un à partir du
moment où chaque citoyen un droit de
réponse à ce qui se passe dans la cité
ce que je dis dans le pays
alors effectivement aujourd'hui on a
parlé de la démocratie participative et
délibérative de la convention citoyenne
donner la parole à ses citoyens
donc nous sommes légitimes alors
maintenant nous ne sommes pas élus et
c'est la raison pour laquelle et on se
bat pour ça depuis le début pour que
vous parlementaires députés et sénateurs
venir la rencontre des citoyens
venez à la rencontre de cet ovni qu'on
appelle la convention citoyenne et
beaucoup se sont approchés et se sont
rendus compte que finalement cette cette
initiative
elle peut être est peut-être un fruit
réellement porteur et démocratique et
justement à la fin de la convention
on souhaite travailler avec vous on
souhaite peut-être venir vous voir à
travers vos commissions et savoir
comment à condition que votre travail
soit repris et à cette expression dans
la bouche du président qui portons
parfois à questionnement sans filtre une
reprise sans filtre qu'est ce que ça
veut dire vous attendez de lui qu'ils
reprennent les propositions via des
textes de loi exactement in extenso où
un référendum où vous êtes d'accord pour
donner une contribution et qu'elles
soient rediscutées quitte à être un peu
changé alors le son filtre c'est vrai
qui a plusieurs
plusieurs explications au départ lorsque
cette proposition et est arrivé sur la
table c'était par rapport au référendum
au référendum
qu'est-ce qu'on fait partir au
référendum et qu'à partir du moment où
sa part au référendum
faut que ça parte sans filtre alors
c'est vrai qu'il sait à positionner en
tant que chef de l'état mais il ne faut
pas et vous venez de le dire discréditer
et on ne veut pas le travail des
parlementaires
donc il faut qu'il y est vous vous plage
des deux vous positionner comme des
partenaires démocratiques exactement
exact matthieu orphelin sur cette
question la légitimité elle est légitime
cette question oui j'entends les
craintes je les partage pas parce que
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que démocratie participative et
démocratie représentative s'enrichissent
mutuellement et que la d'avoir les
citoyens au plus près et avec ses 150
qui viennent aussi de la crise des gilet
jaune du grand débat moi je crois que ça
renforce la décision un certain nombre
de vos propositions c'est exactement ce
que j'entends sur le terrain à ranger
dans les eaux nord joue sur les aides à
la rénovation énergétique par exemple
c'est clair qu'il ya une concordance
parfaite entre ce que vous proposez est
ce que moi je vois sur le terrain mais
pour rebondir ma proposition très clair
aux collègues et peut-être à son groupe
parlementaire justement une façon de
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas de
concurrence entre la convention et le
parlement est ce que vous seriez prêt à
porter avec nous cette proposition d'une
grande loi au parlement dès cet été
ce qui nous permettrait d'avoir les
débats effectivement sur les grands
thèmes que les 150 citoyens ont mis en
avant la mobilité la rénovation
énergétique la consommation est ce que
ça vous serait de nature à vous rassurer
et moi je crois que nous pourrions
collectivement d'une façon
transpartisane envoyé ce message très
clair au président de la république en
disant nous les différents groupes de
l'assemblée nationale nous souhaitons
débattre de ses 149 proposition d'union
nationale
un certain nombre de points de
convergence vous évoquez la rénovation
énergétique c'est déjà un vrai sujet
dans beaucoup de collectivités les
régions les départements les intercoms
de calendrier tout à fait et ça je
l'entends bien en revanche je suis sans
doute un peu plus critique quand il
s'agit parce que ça fait partie des
propositions d'obliger éventuellement
des propriétaires bailleurs à rénover
leur logement
moi j'en connais des quantités chez moi
qui sont pas propriétaires de dizaines
d'immeubles
ce sont des petits propriétaires souvent
des artisans d ancien maçon menuisier
qui ont ça en complément de retraite ils
n'ont pas nécessairement les moyens de
mettre sans aide
attention c'est avec des années mais
j'ai encore bien et donc moi je suis
tout à fait partant pour qui est ce
débat démocratique et au sein du
parlement je peut pas à la fois daigné
d'une certaine façon une légitimité et
une absence de débat au parlement et la
refuser la romagne à la télé de la
mesure elle est juste par rapport à la
question le calendrier me paraît
honnêtement en juillet impossible d'en
mois cc c'est vraiment tombé si bas
c'est pas un revers de main mais c'est
trop ambitieux à minima un projet de loi
doit avoir une évaluation doit avoir une
étude d'impact qu'il faut savoir comment
on finance tout ça déjà on ne sait même
pas à ce stade aujourd'hui comment on
finance la sortie de crise du coc vide
avec quand même quelques petits
milliards qui se baladent ici ou là on
vient un moment où sa fusée nous pas dit
récemment mais se pose est est-ce que
c'est le moment en pleine crise
économique quand les gens ont peur au
fond de la pauvreté et du chômage que de
leur demander des efforts pour
l'écologie quitte à être incités c'est
c'est nous les français qu'ils aimeront
ce chemin la france à dire je voulais
effectivement dire que c'est une grande
avancée démocratique ou plutôt un retour
à la démocratie puisque la stocco cratie
faisait partie de la démocratie
athénienne le tirage au sort
mais j'aurai une petite critique
néanmoins ou une 150e propositions pour
l'aider noter c'est l'école moi
spécialiste des questions d'éducation et
je trouve que là vous n'avez pas été à
la hauteur je vous dis vraiment
nettement chasse et loire éducative pas
assez loin et pas assez c'est à dire
qu'en fait vous voulez changer le code
de l'éducation
alors que le code de l'éducation prévoit
d
à l'écologie a pas de souci là-dessus
l'éducation à l'environnement et au
développement durable tout à fait mais
c'est déjà le cas en fait c'est déjà
devrait faire quelque chose de fait
transversale en fait il aurait fallu
effectivement lire tous les textes en
matière d'éducation et ça c'est pas
grave que vous l'ayez pas fait mais tout
ça existe déjà et en revanche faire des
propositions beaucoup plus novatrices
donc on va passer dans le positif j'ai
moi j'en ai trois très simple à faire un
jardin dans chaque école un jardin dans
toutes les écoles tous les lycées tous
les collèges d'ailleurs ça existe un
jardin d'enfants qu'à l'habitude de
pêcher à la cantine de manger ses
propres légumes c'est pas etc
deuxième chose 50% du temps de l'école
consacrer à sa sauver la planète vous
savez les les questions d'autonomie
d'établissement 50% du temps c'est
l'école c'est le collège c'est le lycée
qui décide d'organiser son temps et je
pense que là vous serez d'accord aussi
est la troisième proposition c'est que
chaque enfant chaque collégien chaque
lycéen et un projet un projet en matière
environnementale pour son quartier
c'est trois propositions extrêmement
concrètes alors que vos propositions a
essayé d'en écrire un texte qui est déjà
écrit mais souvent en france on parle
tout le temps du truc concret et ensuite
on vient à la philosophie sur sur la
question de feeling au stade mais pour
répondre d'abord à françois durr parfait
mais je valide ou trois propositions
vous deviez vous avez entendu des
critiques elles sont un peu sous jacente
avec avec les républicains écologie trop
punitive
quand je regarde les syndicats
d'employeurs ils disent interdire obligé
taxes et voilà les trois mots qui
reviennent en permanence aux fous pas
assez de bonus d'incitation trop de
malus trop de contraintes qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cette question là alors
la première chose que je réponds c'est
que peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas encore lu
li 6 146 pages de nos de nos
propositions pour dire qu'il n'y a pas
assez
je reviens encore de cette notion de
justice sociale il ne faut pas l'oublier
on est les premiers à ne pas l'avoir
oublié ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que aujourd'hui ce qu'on a voulu ce
qu'on a voulu dire c'est que bien sûr
vous avez tout à fait raison
tout est écrit en à la charte de
l'environnement on a des textes écrits
sauf que ce n'est pas suffisamment
appliquée il n'y a pas assez de manière
contraignante un mécanisme de contrôle
pour le faire voilà pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a voulu aller plus loin vous ça
vous donne l'impression qu'on réécrit
non on ne réécrit pas on va peut-être
s'axer sur des points des facteurs qui
vont être importants qui vont être
vecteurs et la de changement c'est je
pense que c'est ce qu'il faut retenir
alors dire obligeait finalement ces
difficultés que les lois dirrell
sanctionné c'est déjà dans les textes de
loi je me rends les directives sur les 2
3 e on les a déjà assez sanctions et de
l'église sauf qu elles ne sont pas
appliquées alors dans l'impression dé
découvrir les noms pour avancer et je
vous donne la parole juste après puisque
vous dites il faut aller un peu plus
loin on est étonné de découvrir un mot
que je ne connaissais pas
personnellement le mot écocide écocide
qu'est ce que c'est une nouvelle
infraction un crime contre
l'environnement explications rabique à
néant revient en plateau après la marée
noire de l'erika
l'explosion de fukushima ou encore les
incendies en amazonie autant de
catastrophes environnementales que les
écologistes voudraient voir qualifiée d'
écocide écocide le mot a paru en 2010
dans le dictionnaire vient du grec au
ico et sid du latin oxydes airs et hué
concrètement détruire notre maison selon
la convention citoyenne l'écocide
criminalise toute action ayant causé un
dommage écologique gras
en participant aux dépassements
manifester non négligeable des limites
planétaires
ce terme encore inconnu du grand public
il y a peu de temps
et pourtant popularisé dans les années
70 après l'utilisation vietnam par
l'armée américaine de l'agent orange
depuis des associations
environnementales et maintenant des
citoyens milite pour sa reconnaissance
dans la constitution
avec pour conséquence des peines
d'emprisonnement et de lourdes sanctions
financières avant que la convention
citoyenne ne s'en saisissent les députés
socialistes ont bien tenté en 2019 de
faire entrer le terme dans le droit mais
sans succès quelques mots simplement
d'abord pour vous remercier finalement
parce que je crois que dans vos propos
vous avez été très clair ni aujourd'hui
ni demain
vous les reconnaître l'écocide dans le
code pénal la proposition de loi a été
jugée trop floue par la majorité
matthieu orphelin qu'est ce que ça
apporterait d'avoir ce crime déco side
dans notre droit pénal
la reconnaissance globale ça donne un
cadre sur la reconnaissance de des
atteintes à l'environnement et notamment
sur des dysfonctionnements majeurs comme
l'a très bien dit le reportage marée
noire ou au type d'atteinte très forte à
l'environnement lors sonar au monsieur
molson arrow au brésil par exemple qui
pourrait être condamné et empêcher de
faire ce qu'il fait en amazonie ou pas
assez le président en exercice
franchement ya sur ce que l'on maîtrise
je crois que sur des affaires comme
lubrizol ou d'hôtes d'autres choses
enfin elle enrichira tout ça mais après
globalement c'est une notion qu'il faut
mettre au niveau national européen puis
ensuite la marque dacia dans un
environnement international
phil goss qui est juriste oui ça ne
marche que dans un environnement
international aujourd'hui en droit
français en droit interne réellement
alors on peut toujours trouver que ça va
pas assez loin et ces femmes et on peut
déjà pénalement largement réprimé
l'américain est encore une fois à juste
titre là où c'est plus compliqué c'est
de dégager de vraies responsabilités on
parle du brésil du président brésilien
effectivement mais il ya tout ce qui pas
vu pas pris et sur lesquels on n'est pas
capable de mettre la main en réalité qui
vous allume des centaines de feux en
forêt amazonienne et et ailleurs donc
je suis assez partagé fo n'exclut en
rien par principe est de toute façon on
voit bien aujourd'hui que pénalement les
atteintes à l'environnement doivent et
seront de plus en plus poursuivis parce
que l'opinion publique est prête et
parce qu'on doit aussi protéger notre
environnement je crois que là-dessus on
a plus ou en tout cas moins de
frontières artificielles très partisane
et en sept minutes dans c'est pas si
simple et aux états unis
françois pour terminer ce débat est ce
qu'on en parle des atteintes à
l'environnement est ce que l'écologie
sera au fond présente dans cette année
2001 de campagne alors elle aurait pu
l'être où elle aurait dû l'être parce
que d'un côté vous avez donald trump
leur donna truax et le président ayant
le moins écologique
il l'a dit et il l'a fait il l'a fait
s'est retiré de l'accord de paris et il
a détricoté dans son territoire toutes
les lois en matière environnementale de
barack obama
donc c'est du très concret et de l'autre
côté il a contribué à verdir le parti
démocrate
les élections de 2018 ont amené un
certain nombre de députés très très
écolo et en particulier alexandria
occasio cortès qui est vraiment l'égérie
du green deal oui voilà le fameux new
deal à le fameux new deal vert des
américains alors et hénon et finalement
cette campagne on a un job hayden qui
est pas forcément le grand leader
écologique on aurait pu imaginer et
trois déceptions en matière d'écologie
la première c'est tous les clans
candidats climatique et bien ont perdu
dans les élections primaires les trois
c'était kamala harris
elizabeth warren et bernie sanders que
joe biden un plan en matière climatique
qui est un implant c'est très simple je
vous donner un chiffre
avec 7 milliards de dollars pour
émission zéro en 2050
le plan de sanders était 16 milliards de
dollars
et puis surtout parce que le système
américain fait qu'il va pas vouloir se
fâcher avec gaz
de schiste pétrole de schiste notamment
la pennsylvanie qui va compter de
manière très très important il ya quand
même une bonne nouvelle c'est que on
n'est pas dans un système centralisé et
qu'en fait on a deux gouverneurs aux
états unis qui sont des gouverneurs vers
le gouverneur andrew cuomo de l'état de
new york
le gouverneur jerry brown convoi qui est
de l'état de californie et à eux deux
c'est la population française quasiment
cessé ses traits banque ses 31 ans
marion bce c'est réduire les quotas
imposés talent des émissions de carbone
jusqu'en 2050 ils ont dit si vous voulez
pas négocier avec les américains
vous n'avez qu'à négocier qu'avec les
californiens et les new yorkais et on
résoudra le problème de l'environnement
merci beaucoup françois merci à vous
d'un mot puisque le débat s'achève
qu'est ce que vous dites à emmanuel
macron chine nous regardent ce soir
avant de le rencontrer en tête à tête
ne nous décevez pas c'est possible c'est
possible vous avez donnez vos voeux aux
millions de français en disant je veux
réformer sur trois plans l'éducation la
santé l'environnement
c'est maintenant à parler lui merci à
vous on va terminer avec ma journée à
l'assemblée comme tous les soirs
thomas des prêts va nous parler des
animaux en politique n'est ce pas thomas
exactement hier un rapport a été remis
aujourd'hui au gouvernement sur la
maltraitance animale mais pas forcément
celle qu'on imagine
je vous raconte tout ça
on a tous déjà vu les images terribles
dans les abattoirs publié par
l'association l214 ou encore les tracks
d'ours dans les pyrénées
là ce sont des animaux domestiques dont
il s'agit un député la république en
marge veut interdire les animaleries et
mieux sanctionner ceux qui maltraitent
leurs animaux de compagnie on est allé
le rencontrer et ce député c'est vous
loïc dombreval vous proposer de protéger
les animaux domestiques
en ce moment on parle beaucoup des ours
des animaux protégés s'étaient pas eu
qu'il fallait protéger en premier les
animaux de compagnie on a l'impression
que tout va bien pour eux parce qu'ils
étaient une compagnie qui sont dans les
foyers est en réalité ils sont 200
milles et raboté d'abandonner tous les
ans donc croire que l'animal de
compagnie au prétexte qu'ils dans les
foyers est un animal qui s'en sort bien
c'est pas vrai en réalité ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on se rend
compte quand on analyse les différents
codes qui sont censés les protéger que
on pénalise plus par emprisonnement ou
amandes un banc public un objet public
qui a été coupée en deux ou un statut
comme statut qu'un chien qui a été
coupée en deux donc là il ya une forme
d'incongruités qu'il faut réparer à mon
avis ils rééquilibrent est un petit peu
tout ça et vous vous proposez même
d'interdire les animaleries oui parce
que dans les animaleries qu'est ce qui
se passe on a un des achats d'impulsion
et on peut pas me faire croire le
contraire
il ya des achats d'impulsion parce que
le vendeur est là pour vendre il ya des
objectifs de vente et donc qui poussent
pour vendre ces animaux donc moi je dis
il faut qu'on fasse en sorte de limiter
sa charge certains d'impulsion et de
faire en sorte que l'animal soit acheté
chez un éleveur professionnel ou amateur
et dans un refuge et protection animale
s'afficher avec des animaux c'est un
classique de la communication en
politique souvenez vous ces images au
salon de l'agriculture ou encore
baltique
le labrador de françois mitterrand fils
est le chien de françois hollande ou
plus récemment jacky le mini hamster de
bruno le maire publié sur son compte
instagram pendant le confinement nous on
a voulu savoir si les députés avaient
eux aussi des animaux de compagnie
est-ce que vous avez un animal de
compagnie non non j'ai eu un petit temps
à lapins mais vraiment ça n'a pas duré
longtemps on a un chien une petit lulu
c'est quand même les vers de terre du
lombricompost
que je connais pas tous par leur nom de
famille et qui travaille beaucoup et qui
font un compost de qualité
la proposition de votre collègue
d'interdire les animaleries
qu'est ce que vous en pensez il ya
certainement des choses à améliorer au
niveau des animaleries du traitement des
animaux en leur sein je bave afana de
l'interdiction à tout va et surtout de
la non prise en compte de la réalité des
choses en tout cas depuis ce matin le
sujet est sur la table du ministre de
l'agriculture didier guillaume peut-être
qu'un texte de loi verra le jour sur le
sujet mais ça on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler dans ma journée à l'assemblée
absolument thomas et ça fait réagir
cette chronique en plateau merci à tous
les trois et bonne route avec ses
propositions citoyennes c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vous de m'avoir
suivi tout de suite c'est votre soirée
documentaire avec jean-pierre graciant
rester avec nous sur lcp à demain
[Musique]